J: Hey guys, how's it going? I'm so excited because today in my kitchen we're not baking! M: No J: And I'm with Miranda
M: What's up guys! J: I'm so excited. M: I'm so excited you are one of the originals
J: Yeah, I feel like I'm the grandma of youtube at this point
M: You are, you're really old
J: Suuper old M: Yeah J: I could probably be all of your moms M: Yeah probably J: For sure
M: And mine too so
J: Maybe!
Since its the holidays
And we're getting really festive. I thought it'd be really fun if we can make some holiday sweaters
M: Oh, perfect I love sweaters J: Or t-shirts because I wasn't sure what you'd be into M: I like a sweater
I'm into a sweater J: So I got these at Target
M: Oooh J: Super fancy, only had one red one and then this one M: Hashtag ad. Hashtag sponsor. J: I wish, if you guys want to hit us up
M: It got caught on my microphone!
Mayday, mayday, mayday! J: Oh no!
It's gonna be okay! M: MAYDAY! J: You need help! M: Its stuck!
Got it
J: Oh phew. We've got t-shirts you know if you feel like gettin' wild M: Oh fun, okay J: Red looks really good on you
so you're in luck M: I know I love red. It's one of my favoritest colors J: We've also got some of these little lights
Check this out!
J: You can put lights on your sweater M: Yes, I love it J: Battery powered
M: *gasps* We have sparkles?! J: Oh, of course we do
J: Look at these little snowmen! M: *gasps* Snowmen!
M: And look, they got this whole box full of ribbons
J: And
Something else... letters? M: Do you have any animals?
Animals?
M: Like dead ones?
J: Dead ones *looks around* M: To like put on it, you know like, it might be cute to have like a dangling dead animal
J: I actually just- M: Like a dead bird a mouse
J: I did M: Who doesn't have dead animals in their house?
J: I had a bird M: That's unfortunate, but we'll have to live with it J: Yeah HAD is the opportune word here
M: Ooh presents, this is amazing so should we just get started? J: I think we do yeah, I mean should we have like a little competition?
M: Yeah, well, I'll win but we can do that, if you want to
J: We can do a little pole because people can vote on youtube did know that?
M: Yes, did you make that up? Did you create that? J: No M: Okay J: But I'll take credit for it M: Okay
J: I don't even know how to do this - do you just jam it in there? M: You jam it in, you stick it in the hole
J: There's two holes though M: Well, thats confusing
J: What do you do for the holidays, anything fun?
M: Um I try not to talk to anybody and
I make sure I get everything I want or else I will spit in my mom's drinks J: Oh goodness gracious
What kind of drinks does she like? M: She likes tea and water which is disgusting, I hate the taste of water
Do you like the taste of water? J: I'm not- I don't think it has a taste really
M: Water has a taste, think about it! Have you tried fiji water? J: You're right, it does
M: Have you had potty water? J: Not potty but I've definitely had fiji water which-
M: Have you tried sink water? J: Yes
M: See? They're different tastes J: You're right. I like smart water because it makes me feel really smart. M: I'm gonna say
I'm very disappointed in you because there's no batteries in this J: I've got batteries, don't you worry!
M: I was worried J: How many- how many A's is it? M: It says two double- triple- double J: Be right back! M: Take your time J: I'm taking...
My time
M: Oh hey missed you J: Hey M: Girl. Oh, okay perfect J: Here you go, that's nice. Oh! Wow, look at this one
This is nice
M: Wowww
J: We could probably cut them in half then we can share
M: Yeah do you have any scissors? J: Uh, I have a knife M: Ooh, I love a knife J: Careful
It's sharp
M: I'm ready for this. This is gonna be the best thing you ever saw J: I love the holidays
M: I think they're annoying I just- I wish that all I had to do was just get presents and not talk to anybody
M: This glue gun isn't freaking working, Justine J: Oh there it is, its comin' out, its comin' out! M: Its squirting
J: There it is! M: It's squirting
J: Yeah, it's a little- it's a little squirt
M: If you're not fans, do not vote for me. I'm gonna unsubscribe to all of them
J: I'm trying to glue these lights on but I have a feeling it's not gonna work out so well M: It's gonna work, have faith
J: Do you have a favorite, uh, like a holiday snack? M: Um, yes, I like macaroni and cheese
J: My sister does as well M: I didn't ask what your sister likes, Justine J: I just-
M: So I don't know why you just told me that because I didn't ask about your sister J: I'm trying- M: I don't care about your sister J: -to relate
M: I don't want to have anything in common with her
I do not trust her. Well my glue gun is already out of glue
So that's a minus for you on the hangout factor of being friends J: Yeah, I'm pretty upset too, mine's empty already
M: You knew that you had a huge celebrity like me coming over
And you got the sale guns J: Well but they were pink and pretty and I was like 'Oh my gosh, Miranda's gonna loove iit!'
M: What do you want for christmas? J: Ooh, I would like a new drone, how do you feel about drones?
M: Like an airplane? J: Kind of M: I don't believe in airplanes, I think it's a conspiracy theory
J: Let's talk about it M: Why do you think those windows are so small? I think we're just driving. I think the  windows are just
movies, they're just pictures. I don't think you're actually flying
J: I think you're right M: I think you go to the twilight zone or something and then you end up in a new place
J: Everything that I thought I knew is not anything that I know M: See? J: Oh my gosh
M: You're gonna love what I'm doing J:  I can't wait to see it, I'm excited M: If you don't wear it every day this month
I don't know if I can talk to you ever again J: Well
I hear that you're having a party that I'm invited to M: Yes, my New Year's Eve party J: Very excited about it
M: You better come J: We made something really really awesome on Miranda's channel M: Yes J: We made a cake pop with an iPhone inside of it
M: Yeah, dreams come true
J: It was pretty much like a dream that I didn't even know that I had and I had it and I didn't even know it. I mean
I know it now M: We just pretty much changed the face of humanity with that one
J: I know - Wow! Hot- is hot- glue, jeez!
*inhales*
I think I burned off all of my fingerprints, do you know what that means? M: Good thing you have the face recognition phone now
J: I was gonna say we could commit crimes now
M: *gasps* Do you have a plan with yours or are you just kind of going for it?
J: You know, I'm just using- this is more like an impressionist type thing, you know, I'm just sort of like feeling like real impress *laughs*
M: Oh an impress- like you're impressing yourself? J: I'm impressing myself with every squirt of this glue gun
M: Mistakes are in the eye of the beholder so maybe your mistakes are another person's beauty or maybe you're just not talented
But that's not for me to decide. Do you see what I'm doing? J: It actually looks really good! I-
Wow!
M: Just wait J: Oh man! M: Wait till I'm done, Justine
I'm blowing your mind! J: Mine looks like- M: I'm making a Christmas-freakin-cat J: I don't even know what I'm making. I think this is a state.
But I don't know my states M: Is that Texas? J: I don't know, I think I'm gonna change it up
Maybe I'm gonna do like um something else, like a Christmas tree M: Oh, what's this for? J: This looks really awful
M: Did you ever do Christmas plays when you were younger? J: Hmm, I think I was like the baby Jesus once M: You were Jesus?!
J: Yeah, I was like a baby M: So are you a boy or are you a girl?
J: I'm a girl, but I was still baby Jesus
M: But Jesus is a boy - or is it 2017, you can be whatever you want?
J: You can be whatever you want but that wasn't 2017, this was like...
J: I don't wanna do the math
Ooh! Look at this little greenstick M: You know, they don't really work too good J: No, this sucks
M: Well, it's your fault for getting the knockoff brand J: I didn't know, I mean is there like a glue gun brand that people use?
M: Um the ones that work
J: OH GOD ITS HOT
M: Did you burn yourself again? J: Yes
M: Justine is such an idiot
J: Ready for crimes!
M: Is that true you can burn off your fingerprints
and then you can do a crime and no one will get in trouble?
J: Well, yeah, it makes sense because you don't have a fingerprint, right? So as long as you don't leave a blood trail like they're never gonna find
you M: I can't get this freakin glue to stay, you're right this glue sucks! J: Sorry
M: Everything's not awesome. That's not, umm, royalty free so do not put that in
Just like put in another tune J: I will Both: Everything is awesome
Both: It's cool to be a part of a team
J: Everything is awesome! M: You better put something else in there and you're gonna get flagged J: You know it's worth it for that because-
M: Demonetized!
J: My favorite movie was the lego movie M: I thought you were gonna say your favorite movie was called demonetized
J: No M: Which sounds like a horror movie for youtubers J: Yeah, but I think it might be like a real-life- M: Yeah, unfortunately, it's a-
Both: True life
J: Ah! I burnt myself again, I literally just touch the tip-
M: Justine- J: and I'm burning
M: I don't think you should say things like that out loud. I said that once and got in trouble - especially don't yell it
at church. Cuz that's where I yelled it, and I got in really big trouble
J: In church? M: Yeah,
Demonetized! J: Wowee! I don't think this is gonna hold up on my body if I try to put this on M: Watch this, watch this
You just gotta like squirt it on and flop it on top, all right. I'm gonna put glue on this thing
J: Now I'm using a green
Gosh, I think we should invent a glue gun that works
M: I think we should invent a
T-shirt company because I am crushing the game J: Would you sell it on ebay? M: We could put this in a mystery box
So we need to try that next
J: I agree. I really want you to meet my friend, but she hasn't been around in a really long time
M: You do not have friends, Justine J: Well, thats why she hasn't been around for a while - but her names eJustine
And she used to be my roommate M: Oh really? J: And some things happened, so M: What happened?
M: She didn't want to be your friend anymore? J: She didn't, I might have like- I might have injured her
Do you need me to help you? Do you need some glue? M: No, I do not need your help look at your sweater
J: It's really the best that I think I've ever done
M: Do you need any other presents or can I steal these? J: You can have them
I really had high hopes for this
I feel like that's a good life lesson M: To have high hopes? J: No, set your expectations very very low
And anything that happens
Is incredible. Think about it
M: AH, I burned myself!
Danggit! J: Do you need something? M: I blame you J: I'm sorry, I know it's really hot M: Everything is awesome
J: Cool to be a part of a team
M: Everything is awesome J: Are we a part of a team now?
M: Not if you're on it J: Oh. Do you think you'll wear this to your, uh, New Years Eve party?
M: No because Christmas will be over J: True M: So, I'll probably wear something even prettier than this
I'm getting pretty close to done, though, not gonna lie J: I think I am too cause I'm sort of giving up
M: Should we try to put 'em on? J: I mean, maybe lets hold 'em up and show everybody M: Okay
M: Alright, well. Yep. Lots of things falling.
(Oh gosh) Lots of things- oop, things breaking(Oh noo, wow!), things falling, oh my goodness (Well, nope) oh, okay (Oh gosh!), well this is working out (More noises of surprise)
M: That's really good J: That was my light. Oh, that's like the whole- that's the whole thing
M: There we go, fixed it. I have to turn mine on! Well mine is the pussy tree!
It's a kitty cat Christmas tree, but she doesn't discriminate against garbage
So I put the garbage on too because trash can be presents too J: I don't even have a description M: Yours is...
trash J: Yeah, this is actually trash. I feel like this is something that that cat would definitely discriminate against M: Maybe my cat-
This is a toy for my cat because it's got string J: Yes! M: So maybe they're- they go together J: Should we put them on? M: Yes, for sure
J: Okay M: This is amazing. Oh, do you need help? J: Oh, thank you M: They look good!
Look it - I even have glue sticks on mine, in case- J: Oh my gosh
M: I need to glue- if something falls off, I can just grab one of those
J: I feel like, so this was my plan, I was gonna wrap this around my arm M: Oh, thats nice
M: I like the placement of my presents J: Oh thats good, thats nice, I've put my presents right here
M: I think we look really nice personally, I think mine is better
J: I have to agree so even if you guys want to vote
J: There'll be a pole somewhere on this video and feel free to vote, whose sweater do you like more? M: Mine
J: I'm definitely voting for yours to be honest with you M: Me too J: I don't think anyones even gonna like look at mine twice M: Well my cat can play with yours
See? They're playing together - DEMONETIZED
J: Well I think these turned out pretty great
And I'm looking forward to wearing this for the holidays and- M: Wait, Justine, we didn't do a fashion show J: Okay
M: Ready? Cue the music
M: Okay, turn it off
J: Alright, its done
Thank you guys so much for watching make sure you go check out Miranda's channel and subscribe we made something super super fun
We made a- do you wanna tell them? M: Yeah, a cake pop
With an iPhone inside of it the world's biggest cake pop with the phone in it J: It was pretty incredible M: A real, working phone
J: And we're gonna start a baking shop together M: Yep, and a clothing line! J: Yeahh M: But I'll make all the clothes
J: I think you will I'll work on the baking. Happy Holidays, guys. Seeya later! M: Bye!
M: Kay, I'm leaving J: Me too... Wait, I live here M: Yeah, okay, bye J: Shoot